during an earnings call today Ubisoft
CEO Eve gimel shared some new details on
the watchdog's sequel he teased that
watch dogs too we'll have a new tone but
he didn't go into detail on what that
tone would be on the sales side of
things gimel did not offer any specific
unit projections though he said the game
has the potential to be one of Ubisoft's
best-selling games of all time he also
referenced the game as being its
best-selling title of fiscal year twenty
seventeen which would potentially put it
ahead of Ghost Recon wildlands South
Park the fractured butthole for honor
and a new unannounced triple-a IP in
addition Guillermo said watch dogs too
will have innovative gameplay but again
he didn't share any specifics the first
watchdogs sold more than 9 million
copies and its creative director has
been vocal about what he would like to
do with the franchise next earlier this
month an image appeared of what could be
watchdogs tues main character although
Ubisoft has confirmed watchdogs to is in
development it has not released any
further details about the title the game
will launch before the end of Ubisoft's
current financial year which runs
through the end of March 2017 also
during an earnings call today Ubisoft
said it will announce lots of dates for
its upcoming games at e3 2016 which will
take place on june thirteenth and if you
want to stay up to date on everything
that's gonna be happening at e3 stay
tuned to gamespot com
you